[Music]
all right let's go to kathleen in
detroit rock city what's up kathleen
hi john thanks for taking my call thank
you so much for calling
well i never dreamed i'd be calling you
about this but um about a month ago um
my 16 year old
was
in a psychiatric unit in lockdown
because
he had a plan to
commit suicide
and um
so he was there for 10 days
and then um in an outpatient program for
three weeks
so um
we
are blindsided we didn't see
you know that this was coming we knew he
was down
and the pandemic's been hard on
everybody
but um
he went back to school last week so
things are stable
um
[Music]
but we're scared i mean we don't know
you know what this disease is we don't
have any
experience with the psychiatric field so
it's it's all new to us and we're kind
of trying to navigate
and they're kind of over
over extended themselves because there's
so many teenagers that need help right
now
um
and i just don't know how to
yeah we we have no experience we
we don't know
why or you know what causes this but it
it's been diagnosed as a you know it's a
disease really a bipolar
one with psychosis
um
so he does have a diagnosis of bipolar
one with psychosis
that's the preliminary diagnosis and
you know at this point we hope that's
all it is we don't know because it might
be schizophrenia i mean we don't know
maybe timing this is the first time
they've seen him so they don't know
we don't get a whole lot of information
from the psychiatrist unless we
really um are forceful and ask um
so it's been tough for us i we just
don't know how to navigate it
yeah thank number one thank you for your
trust this is scary i've had this
conversation unfortunately
probably 150 times in my career i've had
this conversation a lot and so
it's heartbreaking and it's scary and
thank you for your trust okay
um yeah wow
more than 100 oh god i've had this yeah
okay the first thing here okay and this
is me i'm gonna rattle these off top of
my head and um
and so hang in here with me um as we go
through them okay and you don't have to
write all this down you can just keep
this clip and go back and look at it and
listen to it or but you can't write it
down if you'd like okay okay
first and foremost you and your husband
got to be on the same page
and
where this gets hard for everybody is
one person thinks he's faking it or this
is not a big deal or the doctors are
crazy and the other person
wants to wrap the little your boy in
bubble tape and both sides are
understandable
but both sides point to a
new fissure a new crack in a
relationship
and
you
need each other in this season okay
and often i'll recommend you've heard me
recommend on this show before a million
times and i'll do it a million more
times
i recommend you and your husband getting
out when maybe during school take a day
off of work both if you go somewhere and
sit and exhale
take a pad and a pen and just breathe
and then you got to grieve this thing
because it hurts and it's scary and it
came out of nowhere and you're
blindsided all of those words
you got to hear each other talk about
him
uh david kessler says grief demands a
witness you'll got to get in front of
each other and say whoa what just
happened
okay
okay is that possible are y'all in a
position to do that yeah i think we're
on the same page we're both still kind
of in shock and
we're kind of in the bubble wrap both of
us that's right that's right and that's
eight that's where i'd be if my son i
mean i'd be right there okay i'd be
right there
um but get out and have the conversation
about
what do you think of mental health and
what do you think of it and what do we
think about medication what like have
those conversations just so they're sad
and the goal here is this when i walk
away and we want to say
we are going to
both agree that we need to get a second
opinion a second diagnostic we both
agree that this doctor seemed credible
we trusted him he looked us in the eye
or she looked us in the eye
invited us in to be a part of this
our son's healing
and we trust him and so we're gonna do
what they say because we're not experts
right and sometimes i hear this and
you'll get this a lot why aren't you
doing your own research and my response
is
all right dude if we're googling over
med school then we all have a problem
right you know what i mean
um and that brings me to number two
uh how old's your son
16 16.
so depending on what state you're in
which is most states you are technically
the client
you have access to all of the records
because the kid's a minor
and i would there's a bit like a like a
white coat
like oh this is just us and we don't you
know what
dude
knock the doors down
this is my son i want to know all the
stuff he's seeing saying experience all
of these things
we need to know what he's experiencing
and what y'all diagnosed him with why
you diagnosed him with that i demand a
meeting with y'all
and sometimes they'll have a social
worker that helps mediate those most
psychiatric inpatients do because the
doctors are just going
person to person person
how did the social worker reach out how
was that
that was good um
it was good but they
again it's not like a medical diagnosis
where they can tell you right you got
cancer we're going to treat it this
that it's sort of a floating diagnosis
they don't really know all right which
is disorienting what what kind of meds
are they putting on
a mood stabilizer and an antidepressant
so he's quite imagine he's
pretty low zombie like is the word but
yeah he's pretty low it takes a lot
longer for the antidepressant i think to
come take
a fact the problem that they have with
him though is he's in general he's he's
very shut down and they feel he puts
he's an extremely good student and none
of his grades suffered which we can't
believe
even with all the psychosis he had over
a 4.0
um he wants his driving privileges back
and he wants to see his friends again
he's got friends i mean he had a normal
life and he wants to do his activities
and we just we just don't know how
he is stable but we don't know if we
should let him drive or sure
and because these are all questions
that
um somebody's gonna have to tell me
human contact and interaction with
friends and community and loved ones is
not a good idea for me to take that off
the table
someone's gonna have to tell me your kid
cannot do physical activity because i
know connection and physical activity
are really important for
working through and healing from
depression
bipolar is a different story and there's
a whole range that i know i'm getting
all that right now but
um someone's gonna have to sit down and
tell me don't do those things for me to
take those away
and there's also
a son you almost died
and you have to know in our world that
that has and you being vulnerable back
to him is an important number three
letting him know and there's some of
this
fear that we don't want to say it out
loud because we don't know how it's
gonna affect him
what he's gonna feel is the secret is
the gap
you get what i'm saying
and so there's got to be some sort of
hey yes you we love you you scared us
do you want to talk to us will he talk
to you how's those conversations been
a little bit more a little bit better
every day but not
he's very shut down we can't
my
instinct is to kind of talk talk talk
and impress him but he doesn't
they told us not to press him sure and i
think that's right
yeah he is in therapy as a counselor
yeah twice a week yeah good
would he go on a walk with you or your
husband
um a little bit more with my husband but
my husband doesn't press him to talk so
that's probably why i'm trying not to
it's just my way yeah but so here's
here's the i don't think they say much
on their walk hey that's okay
because they're saying everything
okay one thing you might i'm struggling
with i want him to talk but he won't
talk yeah and right now he's trying to
get he's trying to re
his body is what doesn't feel safe
and he may even buy the fact let's say
he's truly suicidal or when he was
suicidal he he i mean he had a plan he
was he was he truly was ready to go
yeah and he goes through inpatient
for a week or ten days and then he goes
through outpatient for three weeks he
may come to believe
this feeling i have that i want to go is
not a trustworthy feeling it's wrong
i trust you that i actually want to be
here even though my body's telling me
it's time to go
that's less he's got to learn to feel
safe in his body again
and to get to know his new body
especially one that's heavily medicated
and if he's got bipolar one
with
um
with he's hallucinating too right
yep with psychotic episodes then he will
probably be on medication for the rest
of his life and that's okay
that's completely okay
it's not ideal we don't want that but
thank god we live in an era when that's
possible okay
if
he's got
um has epilepsy or has brain lesions or
has any number of other things he grows
out of this it what you know what i mean
so that's where getting a relationship
with that doctor is so so so important
and you are the parents of a minor and
you all have access to that and you can
demand it and if they won't give it to
you somebody will
okay and i would be in same with the
counselor
i want to know how my kid is doing
and i think a beautiful thing for you to
sit down and say hey listen i solve all
my problems by just talking and talking
and talking and i know that doesn't help
would you take a silent walk with me
just once a day
and let your old mom hold your hand
please
try that yeah that sounds good try that
i've started silent walks with my son
like hey we're just gonna go and they're
never silent because when there's no
pressure when i'm not gonna grill him on
math homework or whatever
he feels at peace and then when he's at
peace he feels free to start talk talk
talk talk talking and then i get back
and i've learned more about dinosaur i
don't even know we're talking about
anymore right you remember those days
and again all of this is
practicing reestablishing connection and
safety in his
body um
you have to have to have to have a good
partnership with the counselor and a
doctor moving forward
and i hate that they didn't give it to
you
yeah i think they're overwhelmed right
now i know they are i know they are and
i'm not going to talk about it about
them because i know they're getting
crushed the the teens are we've just
just i mean they're just melting it's
just we're just absolutely stone melting
it's heartbreaking
absolutely heartbreaking um does he have
brothers and sisters
who's a sister yeah how is she
yeah 18. 18. and she's a senior in high
school so
she's going to be leaving
for
college and um
i mean he wants to go away too and just
brought that up the other day out of the
blue and i thought well i don't know if
you're going away or not i mean all that
is up in here you know
yeah and i think a great answer to that
is not no way because that goes into the
see i told you i shouldn't be here
it should be
oh my goodness let's say his name's ben
come on ben that's a
that's a next month decision
today we're about
connecting and getting well we'll make
plans down the road
and or you work we'll work that out with
your counselor as we as we all heal
right and letting him know we're all
healing we're all in this together he's
a part of this unit this unit doesn't
operate without him we need him
one of the things that really was a
light bulb moment for me was reading
things thomas joyner's work he's one of
the preeminent suicide i just had so
many of these as a college the college
dean of students i just kept dealing
over and over and over
and one of the things that was a light
bulb moment for me was he writes about
this feeling of perceived burdensomeness
not only do i not have a group but when
i'm around people their life is less
good because i'm in it
and this is rarely it's almost never a
fact
it's just this
sense and so that's why you see people
who look like they've got tons of
friends and they're happy something
inside of them
tells them that other people's lives are
less good when they're around and so
that's what part of the healing journey
is but that's one of those quiet
we're all healing and we're all going to
go do a thing and i know you want to go
like but i think asking your counselor
i'm talking a million different
directions here
talking to hit the counselor asking some
very direct questions can he go hang out
with his friends at night
should we limit video games or cut them
off completely
what does a um one thing i think would
be great for you and your husband and
him is to have a journal that y'all pass
back and forth on each other's beds and
the only requirement is he's got a ride
and he's got to respond to you too
and you ride in it after he goes to
school says i'm thinking about you today
i want you know that you're loved we
love having you here whatever you want
to say to him and you put on his bed and
then he's got to respond to it and put
on your bed before he goes to school
and it might just be he can he writes
thank you it might just be
today was a good day
today was not a good day whatever it is
great but we're just opening a dialogue
that has never been there
okay and get creative on those things
um silent walks holding hands touch
watching dumb movies whatever it happens
to me i listen to garth brooks on the
way to work today that's the kind of
connection i'm trying to make with my
kid right
i don't i'm just trying he loves 90s
country and i'm trying i'm trying and
the the songs are good they're i'm
working on it but whatever we can do to
start leaning into connection and here's
the final final thing i need you to hear
me say
okay
not your fault
okay okay
okay you're gonna mine everything you've
ever said and ever done and wonder what
you did what you did what you did what
you did right
right that's true
okay
okay don't do that to yourself don't do
that to your relationships and do that
to him
it's hard i know that
but
we're here now and how do we make
tomorrow a little bit better a little
bit more connected
but the i want you to hear me say if
nothing else i've thrown a lot at you
and i'm talking 90 miles an hour
um
nothing else
you have to have a good relationship
with his doctor with a psychiatrist and
with his his ongoing counselor
they've got to have a back and forth
connection and there may be some things
that he says i don't want to talk to
them about
and you tell the counselor that's okay i
trust y'all i want you all to have some
privacy between the two of you
um some confidentiality between the two
of you
just know that if he ever says i'm gonna
hurt myself they have ethical
responsibilities to go do something
about it so they're not just going to
sit on something right
um but i want you to be no they didn't
they didn't they let us know when that
came up good good good good good that's
great but
ask as many questions as you can and
don't let them brush you off and be like
well actually this is how our policy is
i don't care your policies that's my son
it's my son right
and i want him to still be here next
year and the year after that and the
year after that and after that and so on
and so forth
healing is gonna be for the whole family
one more thing one more thing on top of
the one more thing take your daughter
out for breakfast and make sure she's
ask ask her how she's processing all of
this
yeah okay it'll probably be good for
both of you you can tell her hey i'm
scared
caught me blindsided she may have some
insight that you don't know about often
older sisters are brilliant and really
observant
and
it will be a great opportunity for her
to get a ringside seat into what
vulnerability looks like you have a
chance to be honest and direct and say
i'm scared too this scared me to death
this is hard on me and your dad and
she'll go oh this is what being an adult
looks like and it'll be a great gift for
her
okay cool
yes
i think all right thank you we'll be
thinking about you please let me know
how these things continue as they
continue on
this is so hard so so so hard so so so
so hard hard hard
young people if you're listening to this
if you're thinking about hurting
yourself
don't
call somebody
right
now
call somebody
moms and dads if you even have an
inkling that your kid's not doing okay
it's worth more than any meeting you
have to go to any show you're in the
middle of watching any
turn stuff off and go in your kid's room
sit on their bed and say
what's going on
and they may tell you to shut up and get
out of here i'm doing this whatever you
say you're my son you're my daughter
how are you
you're not okay
and it may mean you miss out on a lot i
mean you gotta change
i'm here for you
and moms and dads if you're not doing
okay
you can't do life by yourself call
somebody